the opioid crisis in America is quite
severe in 2018 10.3 million people ages
12 and older misused opioids most of
these people misuse prescription
painkillers often turning to the cheaper
more addictive alternative heroin there
are two types of opioids endogenous and
exogenes endogenius opioids are
neurotransmitters created and regulated
by the body exogenes opioids or drugs
derived from plants and produced
synthetically these drugs are the source
of the modern opioid crisis both
endogenes and exogenes opioids interact
with opioid receptors these receptors
are coupled with G proteins which help
modulate neuron signaling one way that
the use of opioids can affect neuron
Pathways is by preventing
neurotransmitter release here's how it
works in the presynaptic neuron when the
opioid drugs bind to an opioid receptor
the g-protein complex splits into two
subunits G Alpha and G beta gamma the G
beta gamma subunit binds to the
voltage-gated calcium channel making
them unable to open and blocking calcium
ions from entering neurotransmitter
release to the next neuron is unable to
occur because it depends on the presence
of calcium ions in the presynaptic
neuron exogeneous opioids can be
extremely dangerous because unlike
endogeneous opioids they are not
moderated and bind to all available
receptor sites blocking crucial Pathways
between the brain and respiratory system
every day an average of 130 Americans
die from opioid overdoses
now it's known as a chemical compound
that can be used to block the effects of
opioids saving lives in overdose
situations it has a similar structure to
the opioids and binds to the same
receptor site without activating the G
protein this prevents opioids from
binding and keeps the neuron pathway
between the brain and respiratory system
open ensuring that people can still
breathe the misuse of opioids can ruin
lives some solutions help fight this
crisis are to be well educated in the
effects to not misuse prescription
opioids and to seek professional help we
hope that if you or a loved one has been
impacted by the opioid crisis you feel
comfortable sharing your story and
asking for help when needed and remember
avoid the opioid